[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I don't know how
much you know about these two
ladies, but I'll give you
a little bit of background,
and then we'll jump
straight into questions.
So Pin Xiu is famous
for her backstroke,
and recently won more than one
gold medal at the Paralympics.
And I think you've won
three in total, right?
YIP PIN XIU: Yep.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And then Theresa is famous
for her breaststroke--
holds many world records.
THERESA GOH: Held.
SPEAKER: Two-- or held.
Sorry-- and won a bronze medal
at the most recent Olympics.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
YIP PIN XIU: I think she's more
in love with her cats, though.
SPEAKER: Tell me
more about that?
YIP PIN XIU: She
has too many cats.
Is three too many?
SPEAKER: Three is not too many.
I did see your cats.
Yes.
I watched a couple of
videos, doing some research.
They're very cute.
Do you want to tell us a
little bit about your cats
before we jump
into the swimming?
THERESA GOH: Not really.
[LAUGHTER]
I have three cats, and
they are all adopted.
And yeah.
I want some more.
SPEAKER: Do you
have room for more?
THERESA GOH: There's
always room for more.
SPEAKER: OK, so as I
said, we are so honored
to have you here today.
And I think maybe a
good place to start
is if you could tell us about
where your passion for swimming
came from.
THERESA GOH: Hm.
Well, I started when
I was about five.
And that was just for fun in
the public pools in my family.
I think it's a very common
thing for families to go
and swim every weekend
at the nearby pool.
And that was the
same for my family.
And it graduated to something
more when I was about 12.
And a volunteer from the
Singapore Disability Sports
Council sponsored me
swimming with my dad in pool.
I think she has potential.
Why don't you bring her
to the upcoming swimming
championships that's coming
up and see how she does?
So he did that, and
I did pretty well.
And I joined a swimming
program after that
and got into the
competitive swimming at 12,
and really progressed
from there.
YIP PIN XIU: Are you saying
my story or our stories
are exactly the same?
SPEAKER: I'll [INAUDIBLE].
YIP PIN XIU: OK.
That's right.
I have to repeat myself.
It's pretty much-- yeah.
I have two elder brothers,
so I was swimming with them.
And then I got really
bored at the baby pool
so I asked my mom if
I could join them.
And she asked the coach.
Yeah.
So that's how I
started swimming.
But everything else is the same.
THERESA GOH: Similar.
Same thing, but different.
SPEAKER: So it's the family
that inspired the first passion.
And then you were spotted
and your mom inquired.
YIP PIN XIU: No.
I was sponsored as well.
SPEAKER: Oh, you
were both sponsored.
OK.
YIP PIN XIU: That's how, yeah.
SPEAKER: Do you want to
talk about that journey,
then, in terms of what brought
you to the Paralympics swim
team?
So how did you end up
representing Singapore?
THERESA GOH: Sponsored from 12.
And you make small goals
towards bigger goal.
And for us, or for me, it
was just getting better
than the previous competition.
So it just makes
more improvements.
And I didn't really,
like, set out
to want to get to
the Paralympics.
It wasn't a main goal for me.
It seemed really
far at the time.
But, yeah, so I just
made little goals
towards getting
faster and faster.
And before I knew it,
I was at [INAUDIBLE].
YIP PIN XIU: When she was
[INAUDIBLE], I just [INAUDIBLE]
for me.
OK, after the
competition, they asked
if I wanted to join
the elite team.
And so we started
with the elite team.
Initially, training was
just four times a week.
But I remember my
very first lesson.
I was sleeping right in the
car when my dad picked me
up and sent me back.
But it started off tiring.
And eventually, we are going
to become 12 sessions a week,
15 sessions a week before the
Beijing 2008 Paralympic Games.
So I think that was also
how we eventually worked
our way to the Paralympics.
It's just through
being very consistent,
consistent training,
and always wanting
to better my previous times.
THERESA GOH: And it was quite
a jump, I felt like, from--
I used to train
three times a week.
And every session would
have a different coach
because at the time it
was all volunteer coaches.
And from jumping from that
to 12, 15 sessions a week
was not fun.
It was exhausting.
And there were a lot of
things that suddenly you
felt like I have no time for.
But you also see the need
to do that because, frankly,
everyone else is doing
the same kind of sessions.
And if you want to keep up
or you want to be better,
you have to at least do
the same [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
SPEAKER: So one of
the motivating factors
for both of you was
making sure that you
were improving your time
over and over again, right,
which led to more sessions and
further fueling your passion
to beat the previous record.
YIP PIN XIU: Initially,
it started more as extreme
self-motivation.
So I'd been training
because my parents had been,
or I'd been training because
the coach was expecting me.
I'd been training
because of something.
But eventually,
after many years,
it started to be interesting.
It was, I wanted to train
because I wanted to improve.
I wanted to do something better.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: So what are
some of the highlights,
then, because both of you
have been to and represented
Singapore in more
than one Paralympics.
So can you talk us through
some of the highlights?
YIP PIN XIU: I remember Beijing.
Beijing was probably my most--
because before Rio, Beijing
was my most memorable games.
I was pretty young then.
I was 16 years old.
And then I've been to other
international competitions,
but nothing is like the Olympic
and the Paralympic Village.
Maybe I can-- it's almost like--
it's the Google offices.
But the Olympics
is like Google--
THERESA GOH: It has everything.
YIP PIN XIU: Everything.
THERESA GOH: There's
a post office.
There's a--
YIP PIN XIU: There are
food stands everywhere.
There's-- yoga is somewhere,
coffee everywhere.
SPEAKER: You're right.
That sounds like Google.
YIP PIN XIU: And it's
a mixture of everybody
who has worked their hardest
to get to where they are.
It's very nice being in a place
with like-minded individuals.
And everybody just wants to
go there to compete and also
to make--
THERESA GOH: It's just
an experience in itself,
to be honest.
First of all, I don't know
another place that I can go
and I see everybody else
who has a disability.
And not just a disability,
but everyone else
is an elite athlete.
It's a very unique
situation that I don't find
many other places you know?
And it's a real
privilege to be there.
And you feel that
the atmosphere,
it's not tense or
really competitive
unless it's in a
pool or competition.
But--
YIP PIN XIU: Friendly.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
It's friendly and
normal, basically.
YIP PIN XIU: [INAUDIBLE]
THERESA GOH: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
A little bit, right?
SPEAKER: So the
highlight is really
just being there and
soaking up the atmosphere,
and, as you say, being
surrounded by other athletes.
And not even just
athletes, but--
YIP PIN XIU: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: Yeah, exactly.
No, but other highlights
would also be-- for me,
it would be knowing that I was
part of the Paralympic movement
in Singapore, where it
started off as being-- we
started off as being in the home
section of the papers, not even
in the sports section.
And slowly, eventually
Singaporeans
began to recognize
that what we were doing
should also be under sports.
And then after Beijing,
after the wins,
then we got a bit
more recognition.
And then last year, with the
ASEAN Para Games and this year
with Rio.
So we did come a long way.
People in the streets
now understand
what is the Paralympics.
They know what para sports is.
And I think we are both very
grateful to be a part of this.
SPEAKER: So you've moved from
local to front-page news.
THERESA GOH: We're
not-- we're not--
SPEAKER: Sponsors are
being [INAUDIBLE].
It really is, the fact that
everybody knows your name,
right?
YIP PIN XIU: Sometimes people
call me Theresa, and she gets
called Pin Xiu.
SPEAKER: Why?
THERESA GOH: No, but
it's really something
to see yourself in
the sports section
compared to seeing yourself in
the home section, because you
feel like--
I mean, I felt--
at the time, I was still young.
So I thought, oh, that's
nice I make it in the papers.
It doesn't matter
where they put me.
But you realize that there's
a significant importance
in correctly labeling it.
Because if you put us
in the home section,
people don't really think
we are sports, you know.
And gradually, finally
acknowledging the fact
that we are sports, we
are considered sports.
YIP PIN XIU: Athletes.
THERESA GOH: Athletes, yeah.
SPEAKER: And what
was it, do you think,
that changed so that
that relabelling,
the use of the right words,
calling you athletes?
THERESA GOH: It was different
people working together.
I didn't feel like it was
really the reporters' fault.
It was more like
maybe the editors,
knowing you shouldn't
put them there.
They don't belong there
or something, you know.
It's a chain.
And sometimes it just
works out that way
that some people don't believe
that you know who you are.
And it took a lot of hard
work from both sides.
We had to prove our results.
And all of our teammates
and other reporters
were there also pushing
our stories out,
those who believed in us, also.
It was a relative
effort, I think.
YIP PIN XIU: That
was a long time ago.
I was in a restaurant.
I was reading the papers.
SPEAKER: So are there any
lessons or discoveries
that you learned about
yourself along the way?
YIP PIN XIU: Not many.
I feel like who I am is
actually because of swimming.
And swimming has given me
everything good in my life.
But I've learned a lot.
I've gained a big group of
my friends through sports.
But I think this year
itself has taught
me to really trust the process.
And it's not that I
wasn't that confident,
because I felt that, even
though I was really doing,
like, 12 sessions, I still felt
like I was not training enough.
And I think it was just a
kind of psychological pressure
on myself, because
for some people
no matter how much you
do is never enough.
And sometimes I felt like that.
So it was important
for me along the way
to learn how to trust
myself, trust my coach,
trust what we were
doing, and just train
and don't worry
about anything else.
So I think that was one
of the main points I
learned this year.
THERESA GOH: I learned the
same kind of thing, really--
YIP PIN XIU: Copycat.
THERESA GOH: --trusting
and believing,
I think, in myself mostly.
Because the trust I placed in
the team was already there.
I always left it to
the team to lead me.
And the part that was missing
was my trust in myself,
believing in myself.
That was missing.
So a little bit of background.
I was in Athens,
Beijing, London, and Rio.
And in Beijing, I
narrowly missed the bronze
by 0.7 seconds.
And that was my world came
crashing down, kind of.
SPEAKER: [DESCENDING SOUND]
THERESA GOH: It was really bad.
Yeah.
And that was one of
the milestones that
really shook my confidence.
And I had a really hard
time recovering from that
and building
confidence from that.
And-- but that was
also the period
where I learned to
change my mindset,
and going to what's
more happiness.
So before that, I was
very focused on just going
training, and going with
flow, and not really--
and just pushing
beyond, and not really
caring about whether it
made me happy or not.
And then after Beijing, I
realized that I wasn't as happy
as I could be.
And so I changed my
mindset to do things
because I wanted to do it and
more to what makes me happy.
And that, while it
made me happier,
it didn't allow
me to swim faster.
So there's always that,
striking a balance between what
makes you happy, but
what makes you better.
And for me, that was what
I learned in the past eight
years, slowly building
confidence and believing
in myself again.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: And after Beijing, you
took about a year off, right?
THERESA GOH: Yeah,
about nine months.
I went to power
lifting to try it out.
SPEAKER: To try something else?
THERESA GOH: Yeah,
try a new sport.
SPEAKER: And what is it, do
you think, that kind of change
that said, OK, I can
go back to swimming?
And I now am
confident in myself?
THERESA GOH: At that time,
it wasn't really still
at that point.
But it was the fact that, after
nine months, I was at a point
where I needed to decide whether
to go back to swimming or not.
And if I wanted to
go back to swimming,
I had to give up power lifting
because power lifting would
make me too heavy for swimming.
So I had to give up
one or the other.
And so I was thinking power
lifting made me quite happy,
and it was a new environment.
And I hadn't been
in a new environment
because I felt that swimming
was very negative atmosphere
to be in at the moment
when I first left Beijing.
So after nine
months-- it took time
to get the positive
back in my life.
And once I felt
like I was ready,
I had to make the decision
whether to go back to swimming,
And I felt like that I had
more to give to swimming
and I felt like it was time
to give it another shot.
SPEAKER: So in all the
articles I read, it always
talks about your parents.
And they seem to have been
very supportive in both cases.
Do you want to tell
us more about how
they fuel your passion for
swimming and what you do?
YIP PIN XIU: Personally, for me,
I think I work a different way.
I work [INAUDIBLE] micromanage
what I do every day.
So what they did to support me
was they just took a step back,
and they trusted me to do
whatever I wanted to do.
So I was in secondary
school at the time.
And honestly, already I
wasn't a very good student.
But they didn't nag at me.
They didn't force
me to have to study,
even though such a
large emphasis is placed
on education in Singapore.
They gave me the freedom of
choice to choose to swim more.
And they understood that
the Paralympics only
comes every four years,
whereas I could study,
if I felt at all levels,
which I didn't, I could always
redo it the year after.
So for them, really, it was
just actually being there
and agreeing with my decisions.
THERESA GOH: For me,
we are different people
because I need the push.
I'm a little bit less motivated.
So my parents had
to push to training
and make sure that I get there.
But for me, the easiest part
comes after I leave the house.
So they have to wake
me up, and then--
YIP PIN XIU: They
have to kick you out.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
They have to get me
out of the house.
And once I'm out, I'm fine.
And my dad always send me
to training in the mornings
and picks me up after that.
So when I go to
trainings at 6:30,
he would drop me off at the pool
and then jog around the pool.
So it was a team effort.
So I helped him exercise, and
he helped me get the training.
And it was routine.
So I work well with routine.
So I just kept with that
routine for a while.
And my mom was always there.
And when I got home,
there was always
food on the table,
and healthy options.
And yeah, I think just generally
also being there for me.
And they also really
supported my decisions.
I went to [INAUDIBLE]
after secondary school
for a semester.
But I had made a decision
to quit school after that
to focus on full-time training.
So that's also
something that I think
a lot of the
parents in Singapore
may not necessarily agree
with because of the education
system.
But they trusted me and allowed
me to make my own decisions.
And yeah.
They allowed me to be as
independent as I can be.
SPEAKER: Now as the audience
here is little Googlers,
I wanted to switch gears a
little bit before handing it
out to the audience
to ask questions.
So in terms of
technology, are there
any types of assisted
technology that you
use to make your
day-to-day lives easier?
THERESA GOH: I actually
like to use Google Maps.
One of the things
that, especially when
you think about accessibility
in Singapore-- one of the things
that I do maybe different from
people, able-bodied people,
is that when I go
to a new place,
I Google Map the location.
And then I go to
satellite view, and then
I zoom all the way in so I
can see if it's accessible.
So that helps a lot.
I wish it was everywhere.
Even inside buildings,
taking a 3D tour of a place,
that would help a lot
of people because it's
really hard sometimes
to define accessibility
for different people.
So for me, what
might be accessible
may not be accessible
for someone else.
So it's clear when you
can see it, you know.
And so I like Google
Maps satellite.
YIP PIN XIU: I think for
me, sometimes I don't--
because my hands
are a big klutz-- so
I don't really type properly.
So what's good for me
is the voice functions.
But I think sometimes it doesn't
understand a Singapore accent
as well.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Don't worry.
It doesn't understand
my accent either.
YIP PIN XIU: So I
really have to text me,
text me, text me
during the Games.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: I think we
definitely need to train
this on a few more accents.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
I think the world
has changed so much.
It's made it a lot more
accessible for swimming pool.
YIP PIN XIU: And
technology is really good.
THERESA GOH: And it was in Rio.
Was it Rio?
We saw this
technology on a phone
where you can use your
eyes or something.
They can track your eyes.
SPEAKER: Yeah-- retina.
THERESA GOH: For those
who cannot use their hands
or-- yeah.
YIP PIN XIU: And I
really like the dinosaur
whenever there is no internet.
[LAUGHTER]
The space bar one.
SPEAKER: So what do the next 12
months have in store for you?
YIP PIN XIU: I took a year
off to train full time.
So I'll be heading
back to school
in January for four
or five months.
Then in the meantime, I
will still be training.
But I probably wouldn't
be going full-time work.
Then once I graduate, I will
start training full time.
And we have ASEAN Para Games
and world champs next year.
So it's still back to the pool.
THERESA GOH: Yeah,
back to the pool.
No school for me.
SPEAKER: Just training,
training, training.
YIP PIN XIU: You do my homework.
THERESA GOH: Do
you want to fail?
I probably will go back to
swimming for a couple years.
But Tokyo is still unsure yet.
SPEAKER: OK.
So I'm going to open
it up now to the floor.
If anyone has any
questions, do come up.
YIP PIN XIU: You
can ask anything.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming in.
I've got a two-part question.
Firstly, how would you rate
Singapore as an accessible
city as a wheelchair user?
Obviously, there's newer parts,
new buildings like this one,
which are designed with
accessibility in mind.
But then there's parts
of town like Chinatown,
which I can imagine must
be hard to get around.
And then the second
part of the question
is-- you've been
fortunate to travel around
the world to compete.
How does Singapore rank
against other cities in terms
of accessibility, and
which city would you
say is top of the list?
YIP PIN XIU: What
would you rank it?
THERESA GOH: I would say
it's actually not so bad.
I don't know whether
it is because I'm
familiar with the country
and how to get around.
YIP PIN XIU: I give it a 7.75.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
That's very specific.
I would say it's about there.
Yeah.
It's not so bad.
I've traveled alone to
London and around UK.
And we once traveled together
with some friends to Australia.
And I always thought
Australia was really good,
because in some of the
national parks where
I wouldn't expect clean,
accessible toilet, they had it.
And it was really clean.
And for me, for everybody,
being able to go to the washroom
is a basic necessity.
And for me, it is
just that extra thing
about worrying
whether it's clean,
whether it's accessible,
whether there's someone inside,
whether--
there's so many things--
and whether there's
one available at all.
And sometimes you have to be
a bit creative with toilet
situations.
But Singapore's not bad,
especially the transport
system.
MRT is really accessible.
YIP PIN XIU: And we think
[INAUDIBLE] where I'm getting
[INAUDIBLE].
On weekends.
THERESA GOH: UK is really good.
The tram's not very accessible.
But they have options.
You can call for assistance
and stuff like that.
There's still no perfect
country that I've been to.
Singapore, honestly,
comes pretty close.
But it's because I am
probably used to it.
YIP PIN XIU: In places
where we're used to it,
it's quite good.
But 10 minus 7.75,
whatever that's missing,
I think it comes form the
older places, like Chinatown,
[INAUDIBLE], and just some
areas where the steps are not--
from the bare eye,
you can't really tell.
But if you sit on a wheelchair,
and it hits something,
you might fall over.
So I would say we're
actually pretty good.
It's just the
smallest of things.
And yeah-- the
trains are very good.
All the trains have lifts.
Buses have ramps.
I don't like trains.
That's another
thing I don't like.
Yeah.
We get caught in trains as well.
THERESA GOH: The [INAUDIBLE]--
what do you call it?
The holes in the drainage.
Yeah.
So sometimes our wheels
are really small.
They get stuck.
YIP PIN XIU: But the last
we went to Pasadena in 2014,
I thought that it
was really good.
Everything had
wheelchair accessibility.
But I'm not sure about it now.
THERESA GOH: There's still
accessibility for us,
and still certain
types of accessibility
for maybe someone on a motorized
chair might be different.
And we are lucky.
We are mobile.
We can get in and out of
our chairs quite easily.
But from our perspective,
it's pretty OK.
YIP PIN XIU: Do you
think driverless
technology will become
mainstream soon in your car?
SPEAKER: I hope so
because I don't drive.
YIP PIN XIU: Neither.
We need assistive
driving devices.
SPEAKER: I've been
telling my family
for years I'm waiting
for driverless cars.
THERESA GOH: I would use that.
YIP PIN XIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how much do
you think your disability
influenced the
path that you took
and your passion for swimming
and where you are now?
THERESA GOH: I think if I was
not born with a disability,
I probably wouldn't have
come down this path, which
is why I also like to say that
I'm thankful for my disability
because it's opened so many
doors that may not have been
opened for me if I was not
a person in a wheelchair
or a person with a disability.
YIP PIN XIU: I think about it--
if I was not disabled, would
I still be doing sports?
And I think yes, but maybe not
swimming, maybe something else.
I feel I'm a very active
person and competitive person
by nature.
So I do enjoy sports.
But maybe I would just
be in national level,
as in not international.
Like school level or something.
But I probably
wouldn't get this far.
AUDIENCE: I have two follow-up
questions for each one of you.
First, for you,
I liked the story
about the happiness and Beijing.
So what did you feel when
you then eventually won
the next medal?
How was that?
What was that feeling?
Can you describe that?
THERESA GOH: Disbelief,
but mostly relief.
And throughout the whole
race when I was swimming it,
I knew that at any
time, if I had given up,
it would have been over.
But it was just
that fact that there
was that importance of not--
of holding on throughout
the whole race,
and not giving up at any part
that really stuck in my mind
and was so important
because I just
know how close I think
the next person was.
And a slip-up for me would have
meant Beijing all over again.
Yeah.
But when I touched the wall,
it was disbelief and relief.
AUDIENCE: Sorry for
the stupid question,
but I'm not a
competitive swimmer.
So when you touch the wall,
you directly know that--
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
It's on the wall, the time.
AUDIENCE: Oh,
that's pretty cool.
THERESA GOH: Oh, yeah.
It is.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't know when I touched it.
I just look at the clock.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I though
that when you touch it,
it buzzes, and that means
you won or something.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Two requests.
AUDIENCE: Look at me.
I'm not competitive
or sporty so--
YIP PIN XIU: Maybe
she could tell
that she won based on all
of us shouting, like ahh!
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
I could hear everybody.
AUDIENCE: And for you, you
spoke about the newspapers
and the journey from the
local pages to the front page.
So how do you use that
front-page popularity
now outside of sports,
or maybe outside of--
is it really just to maybe make
other people aware of things?
Do you-- I don't know.
You come here,
obviously, but what else
do you do around that?
YIP PIN XIU: I like to
say with great power comes
great responsibility.
So we're very--
THERESA GOH: [INAUDIBLE].
YIP PIN XIU: What?
YIP PIN XIU: Oh, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] spoken about, yeah.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
So we-- I can't get
my thoughts together.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
And now, we are--
not just myself,
but Theresa also.
I think as athletes, one
of our most important role
is to produce results,
because only with results will
other people join our
fight, to fight with us
when it comes to things like
inequality or other things.
When we get results,
then we are in the news,
and people see that there
are gaps in the community
and try to bridge it.
So we, on the other
hand, after the results,
we will try to join
them in this fight.
Not like it's a fight.
But we try to join them
to promote more awareness,
to go to talks, and to--
well, I wouldn't exactly
call us inspirational,
but try to impact people with
our stories, and just to--
SPEAKER: All of us would
call it inspirational.
THERESA GOH: Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You both talked
about how important
it was throughout your journey,
two such great achievements,
and to be self-motivated.
And I just wondered
how different does it
feel to beat a world
record and then
to beat your own world record?
YIP PIN XIU: What if my own
record is the world record?
AUDIENCE: But how different was
that, beating your own world
record at Rio this year?
How different did
that feel to you
when you set the record
in the first place,
when you beat someone
else's record?
YIP PIN XIU: I think getting
a better timing is always
a joy regardless
of whatever I got.
So as long as the
timing that I did today
is better than what I did a
couple months ago, I'm happy.
I'm terribly happy.
THERESA GOH: It is a
different feeling when
you break a world
record and then you
break your personal best.
At the time when I was
breaking world records--
not anymore, but in the past--
it was not really something
that I was focused on.
So it was just like--
oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I broke a world record.
But it was more of the
fact that I was getting
faster that I was happy about.
And then the world record
just came naturally, I guess.
Like, even in Rio, when I
saw my finals, or my heats,
it was the fastest
I've swam ever.
So it was my personal best.
I didn't break a world record.
But I was four seconds faster
than my last personal best
time.
And that was better
than any of the world
records I've ever gotten.
Because it was many years
of not getting faster.
And then finally getting
four seconds off like that,
it's quite a great feeling.
AUDIENCE: First and
foremost, thank you
for what you have
done for our country.
You put it on a world map.
It's all their effort.
But we as a nation get
to share your glory.
So thank you for that.
Secondly, the team is
about accessibility.
But I think--
I don't know about
everyone here--
but this is my first time
in a room with athletes
that are at the
top of their game,
and beating world records,
winning gold medals.
So could you give us
a feel of that access
into when you were competing
for the very first time,
and you entered a pool, or
you entered an arena where
you are competing with the
top, top athletes in the world?
That feeling that you had,
how did you motivate yourself?
How did you tell yourself versus
the last time when you went
over there in true confidence?
What is it that for mentally
you prepare yourself
so it's not just
a physical thing
but more of like your
mental preparation?
YIP PIN XIU: So the
first games [INAUDIBLE].
So I was reminded of
this by my psychologist
like, maybe, two years ago.
So I was telling her
that I'm not sure
if I can do it because so
many things have happened
since Beijing, so many ups
and downs and good things
and bad things that I didn't
know if I was able to.
But then she told me to
just go into my final race
with the mentality that
I had in my first race.
So for the very
first race, I just
wanted to go in and do my best.
In the recent three
races, I've just
been worried about
whether I can do it,
whether I can get
a better timing.
It's just a lot of worry.
And so she told me to bring
it back to when I first
started, because
that's when people
race the best, when they have no
worries, when they're relaxed.
And I needed to adopt
that kind of mindset
into my final race
in order for it
to translate into better
physical movements as well.
So the psychological
and physical part
is very linked even though
we don't really see.
But I don't know how.
It's like magic.
But if I'm too
excited before a race,
my race really
wouldn't turn out good.
So it's really to--
she said this phrase
in Chinese is like--
[CHINESE]
So now, regardless of why it is,
a mountain is still a mountain,
the water is still water.
So swimming pool is
still a swimming pool.
Just go in and do
your very best.
And that's how I went
in on my final race.
Yeah.
THERESA GOH: My most latest
racing in 100 breaststroke,
it felt so--
well, it was different
from any other race
I've swam in because I
felt the most relaxed ever.
So before, three months before
the Rio 100 breast race,
I had a lot of worries.
I had a lot of trouble sleeping.
And that-- yeah.
Plus, we were roommates most
of the time, so she knows.
YIP PIN XIU: In the middle
of the night she was like--
yeah, what happens if I--
THERESA GOH: What
if I don't do it?
Will everybody still love me?
YIP PIN XIU: Then I had
to be a psychologist.
I was like, shh, shh,
stop thinking about it.
THERESA GOH: So just three,
four months of that every night,
it was very tiring.
You know that how you want--
if you want to get
a perfect scenario,
you have to do this, and do
this, and do this, right?
So if it's like a game--
you know how those games,
where you want to hit--
there's a bug going up
and down, and you have
to hit it at the right time?
Yeah, those games.
So it always feels like that.
It feels like a lever.
And I always feel like I
have to be in the middle.
And it was just very
tiring because I
felt I was over-nervous.
And I was like, no.
I'm fine.
I don't care about it anymore.
YIP PIN XIU: A few
days later, she's
like, I don't care
about anything anymore.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
Why am I [INAUDIBLE]?
I don't care.
Two days later, I'd be
like, aw, I can't sleep.
It was just constantly
going back and forth,
and having to find
a middle ground,
and being confident, but not
so worried about the results.
And so when the final
day came, the night
before I slept at 7:00 PM,
I went to bed at 7:00 PM
just to try and fall asleep
and have enough hours of sleep
before my race, and
managed to do that
after drifting in and
out of sleep again.
And then in the
morning, I woke up.
I went to the call room, and
I wasn't nervous anymore.
I was calm, I was
happy, I was relaxed,
and I swam my fastest race ever.
Yeah.
NITHA: Hi, both of you.
I'm Nitha.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's such a pleasure to
see you guys in person.
We've been on the WhatsApp chat.
What I wanted to ask is,
since you guys came in,
I've seen a very infectious
energy and a camaraderie
between the two of you.
So I wanted to ask, does
your friendship also
go a step further where you're
trying to motivate each other
or be there for each other?
Because at Google,
we all work in teams.
And I think for us, that
team bonding and that team
collaboration is important.
So how does it work
with the two of you?
Do you guys fight
at all, or is this--
THERESA GOH: There's a
reason we're sitting so far
apart from each other.
YIP PIN XIU: See the distance?
So you stay there.
THERESA GOH: Of course,
we have moments.
It's not perfect.
YIP PIN XIU: I have to tell
you my story when I first
met Theresa.
THERESA GOH: OK, OK.
We [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, it's really
hard to find someone
you can connect with so well.
And it's good because
we can connect,
and it's a good chemistry.
We can just sit in silence--
it's fine-- or we can talk.
We can do that.
Yeah.
But it's important to
be able to find someone
that you can click with,
for sure, much easier
than with someone you
don't like, right?
YIP PIN XIU: No, you didn't
like me at the start.
THERESA GOH: She was
very annoying to me.
YIP PIN XIU: So right
after I joined the team,
I was 12 years old.
I was a very
excitable young thing.
And she, on the other hand,
was already swim queen.
She's a lot older than me.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm kidding.
Five years is not that much.
Yeah.
But when I first
went swimming, she
would be with the
older people talking.
I would be at the side
talking to the younger ones.
And we never really became
friends or spoke to each other
until we became roommates.
I started swimming
competitively in 2004.
But we only became
roommates in September 2005.
So there was an entire year
of not talking to each other.
But it was only when
I became her roommate
and started chattering
too much in the room
that I melted her
ice-cold heart.
And then from then on, we've
been roommates ever since.
So it's really nice to have
somebody along with you
on this journey,
because I'm not perfect.
On some days when I really
cannot find the motivation
to train and I see that
she's training, I have to go.
And some days I feel I
have to drag her, literally
drag her to training.
So it's really nice just
having company along the way.
And it's nice knowing that
you're not doing this alone.
THERESA GOH: When you
do-- when you go--
you know you're
going to face shit.
And then you know
that someone, they
are going to face the
same thing with you.
YIP PIN XIU: In the morning,
when I first wake up in bed,
I hope it rains.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
We're texting each other.
YIP PIN XIU: And we can
only tell each other.
We can't tell our coach.
I hope it rains, Coach.
THERESA GOH: It will stop.
You think it's going to rain?
[INAUDIBLE]
YIP PIN XIU: Let's lie in
bed for five more minutes.
OK, time to get up now.
NITHA: Can I ask a
follow-up question to that?
We talk a lot about work/life
balance here at Google, right?
And both of you train
so very, very hard.
What do you guys do for fun?
THERESA GOH: There's a
lot of things to do--
go out.
YIP PIN XIU: I think
it's not that hard for us
because we find fun in
the work that we do.
So it's good to enjoy what
you do and find people
that you can relate
and connect with.
But then for us, believe
me, we have free time.
It's not only just
the two of us.
We normally hang out with
other people because--
I don't know-- because we
see each other too much.
THERESA GOH: We
have other friends.
I promise.
We do hang out with a
lot of other friends.
Who have mutual groups and
we hang out together, dinner,
or just a movie, or
just hanging out.
YIP PIN XIU: And you have to
see the amount of WhatsApp group
texts.
[INAUDIBLE]
THERESA GOH: [INAUDIBLE]
YIP PIN XIU: You'll find it.
Guess.
THERESA GOH: Can anybody
guess how many WhatsApp groups
we have in common?
That's so low.
OK.
We have-- go higher.
YIP PIN XIU: Higher?
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
We have 83 groups in common.
SPEAKER: What?
I wouldn't even be able to keep
up with that conversations.
I wouldn't even be able
to keep up with 83 groups.
My goodness.
THERESA GOH: It's so many.
YIP PIN XIU: That's too many.
I think it was 50-something
the last we checked.
THERESA GOH: Yeah.
It's growing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
sharing your stories.
It's really, really
inspirational.
My question is, is
there any technology
that has improved
your quality of life
in terms of accessibility?
And if not, what areas would
you like to see improving on?
YIP PIN XIU:
Driverless technology.
SPEAKER: I think it got stuck
there on Family and Friends
Day.
I just noticed that it's one
of the YouTube Kids ones.
THERESA GOH: Does the-- that's
my-- it's not her phone.
I can move along
with easily and fast.
But I recently
bought this thing,
the extra wheel at
the back of my chair
that can connect and disconnect.
And it helps me go up ramps.
And so it's like a moto--
YIP PIN XIU: A wheel.
THERESA GOH: Yeah, so I just
push once and it will continue.
YIP PIN XIU: Is it
like a Segway-ish?
THERESA GOH: Not really.
Segway, you got to lean, right?
No, this one doesn't lean.
It helps to allow me
to move on carpets,
because it's not so easy to
push a wheelchair on carpets.
Like, little things like
that that doesn't necessarily
make the chair heavier,
that much heavier,
but it adds that extra
help that I need sometimes.
YIP PIN XIU: So it's a
problem finding chairs,
even the most basic of things--
maybe for us, wheelchairs that
are at the same time slick,
but at the same time
still have functions
that help with our lives.
So everything's really bulky.
THERESA GOH: The
lighter the chair is,
the easier it is to push.
But the lighter it is,
the more expensive it is.
And that can be problematic
for the poorer countries.
So a lot of times, you
find that the chairs that
are massive and hospital
chairs, basically.
And it's not easy to push.
It's basically meant
for someone to push you.
And then you remove
that independent factor.
And then they have to depend
on other people to push them.
And then it just becomes
a downward spiral.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming, Pin Xiu and Theresa.
And I just saw the
news that, Pin Xiu,
you just came from SMU, right?
There's a scholarship named
after you in your honor.
You were wearing the exact same
clothes, so congratulations.
YIP PIN XIU: Yes, I was.
THERESA GOH: You
should have changed
AUDIENCE: It was one
hour ago or something.
So I actually have
two questions,
but I suppose there's
only time for one.
One actually relates
to disabilities,
and the other one is actually
Singapore in general.
So the first one was around--
and you don't have to answer
this if it's sensitive.
But during the Paralympics,
Olympics, or [INAUDIBLE],
rather, there was a lot of
celebrations in Singapore,
and also a lot of chatter and
talk about the monetary reward,
and the discrepancies--
I'm not sure this was already
covered-- but discrepancies
between both, and just wanted
to get some of your thoughts
on how you feel about that.
I think you were quoted
in the papers as well.
But it would be great to hear
some of your personal thoughts
and reflections on
the discrepancies
and how that affects--
or whether you
think that's fair,
what you would like to
see changing going forward
in Singapore, and the
perception of Olympians
versus Paralympians.
And then the second thing was--
it's very stark or
very interesting
that swimming seems to be
the sport in Singapore that
earns us medals, both
for able-bodied athletes
and Paralympians.
And just wanted to
get your view on how
we can replicate the success
for other sports in Singapore
as well.
THERESA GOH: I'm going to
touch the first question first.
The easiest way to say is
if you were a Paralympian,
and you had gotten a gold
medal, and your friend is
an Olympian got a gold
medal, and both of you
have gone through the
same kind of trainings,
and basically got
into the same things,
how will you feel if you've
got different amounts?
So that's the way that it allows
you to feel, how we would feel.
But at the same time,
it's also not something
that we worry about because it's
not something we can control.
And I think in
life, my whole life,
it's always not worrying about
something you cannot control.
So you control what
you can control.
And if you control something,
you cannot control it,
it just makes you
more frustrated.
So I think it's also a lot--
we like to compare it to--
because Paralympic sports
is not so competitive--
so I think one of the
[INAUDIBLE] something.
And that's not really
a fair comparison
because there are different
sports with different levels
of competitive level--
not competitive level,
different levels of
numbers of competition.
And swimming has a lot of
competitors, a lot of swimmers.
But then if you compare another
sport, maybe it has two-thirds.
Are you giving that sport
lesser even though it's
an able-bodied sport?
All right.
So I think that's not really
a fair comparison to make.
The main point is
that they probably
don't value personal
disability s highly
as an able-bodied person.
That's how I feel like.
I feel that's the main
base, the foundation of it.
That is why they feel that
we don't deserve as much,
even though they don't--
they may not realize that
they're feeling that way.
YIP PIN XIU: And
they don't realize
that not many people get their
knowledge or their information
from papers or from things.
So if the people at the top--
not exactly the top-- but if
people don't see us as equals,
then people read
the news, and they
see that they're not
equal, they would also
start to have this mindset
that-- oh, maybe they are not
equal, which is a bit painful.
But I think we
don't take the money
thing too hard because
we're really not doing
this for the money.
Yeah.
So maybe you don't have to
increase our amount but maybe--
THERESA GOH: Bring
down the Olympians'.
YIP PIN XIU: I didn't say that.
Yeah.
And what was the other one?
AUDIENCE: How to replicate
the success of swimming.
THERESA GOH: I don't know.
YIP PIN XIU: I feel
I want to try it.
THERESA GOH: Yeah,
swimming, I think
we can achieve a lot more
because we have a lot of events
to win medals in.
So if I have eight events
that I can get medals in,
and bowling has only one,
it's not comparative, not
very competitive-- comparative.
YIP PIN XIU: But it's not true.
Actually, it's just
that for Olympic sports,
we are good at swimming.
But bowling doesn't
have the Olympics.
But we are very good bowlers.
THERESA GOH:
World-level bowlers.
YIP PIN XIU: Our bowlers
win world championships.
THERESA GOH: But they just
don't have an audience.
YIP PIN XIU: Yeah, they
just don't have an audience.
And I think in order
to be a good athlete,
it comes from the culture
of the sports itself.
So some people--
say for swimmers, we
have a lot of swimmers
to look up to.
We know what they do.
We know the science
behind it and everything.
But maybe for some other sports,
some of the athletes are just--
they think that
what they're doing
is the way the
athlete should do,
but it actually isn't the way.
So I think it's really
the culture of the sport
and how the athlete
grows up in the sport.
I wouldn't say we
are super athletes,
but at least we wake up
at 5:00, we sleep on time,
we sleep at 10:00.
But there are some
athletes who go for supper,
and sleep at 2:00
in certain spots.
And maybe that's
why they're not--
THERESA GOH: I think
it's very individual.
YIP PIN XIU: Yeah,
So I can't tell if it's from an
individual, or from a country,
or from a sport.
THERESA GOH: But
I think that it's
also because swimming is
so marketable and so high
profile for weather--
SPEAKER: We're outdoors
here all the time.
That helps, right?
THERESA GOH: Oh, yeah.
And there's a lot of
pools in Singapore.
It helps when a country invests
more in a certain sport.
Triathlon is getting hot.
And a lot more people are
competing in triathlon.
And it really depends on
what people know is out there
and what you're exposed to.
SPEAKER: So I just wanted to say
a huge thank you to both of you
for coming in.
[APPLAUSE]